Eric Voss here with another new
rockstars hot take HBO is The Last of Us
follows the survivors of a worldwide
infection from the cordyceps fungus
spoiler one of your episode one and
potentially more of them right about
this but series director Craig Mays and
teased that there were in his words
breadcrumbs around the neighbor's food
like their biscuits and cookies that
would pay off later now I wondered if
this referred to yeast which is a fungus
that's used in baking and in the games
the fungus did come from imported crops
but in the show I actually think the
fungus is spread by flower specifically
the biscuits Mr Adler feeds NaNa which
Joel refuses joking he's on Atkins which
was an early 2000s Trend diet that
encouraged avoiding flower-based Foods
Ms Adler makes raisin cookies that Sarah
doesn't want to eat and we see a
close-up of those cookies rising from
the heat in the oven Sarah's not able to
find pancake mix anywhere in the house
Joel forgets to bring home a cake and in
the present day of 2023 these string
beans don't look like they're eating a
ton of carbs we see ration cards but not
what they are eating these days damn it
Paul olly what do you just gave a
Hollywood handshake to the end of the
world